Hello.
Is this working?
It's going to be
slightly complicated
holding both this and this.
So if I start holding
this up to my mouth,
just someone wave at me.
So as developers, our bounds
and our responsibilities
in the industry have
changed all the time.
And if you think back
to the start of the web,
it was just text on a screen.
And our goal was to have that
text be read by someone else.
And that was, actually,
quite difficult,
because there wasn't really
anyone else on the internet.
But then we got more
and more developers
working on the internet.
And we had to compete.
We wanted to compete
with other developers
to show that we were
better than they were.
And we did this by putting
our pages in outer space
and centering things and moving
things from side to side.
We really liked the
moving bits on the web.
So we added a whole
bunch of them.
Make it look like there's loads
of complicated stuff going on.
Because the more complicated
it looks, the more complicated
it must've been.
And that makes us
better developers.
We discovered JavaScript
at this point.
And we used JavaScript to create
gray dialogues on the screen.
But then we looked around.
And we realized that the
internet had been infiltrated.
It had been infiltrated
by normal people.
And it was like our parents
had been away for 10 years.
And we'd been all
having this great party.
And all of a sudden they phoned
and said, we're coming home.
And we're like, oh my god,
look at the mess we've made.
We need to clean this up.
And we did.
Usability became a big deal.
The GIFs, the marquees,
no longer cool.
We started thinking about
readability, semantics,
accessibility.
It was a real back-to-basics
move for the web.
We got a new browser
war at this point,
with more budgets
and bigger explosions
then the last browser war.
And Netscape was killed
off in the first scene.
But some of the new
characters were pretty good.
Here we had the Chromes,
the Firefoxes, the Safaris.
A new generation
of developers had
to care about this platform
and browser compatibility.
We started using
JavaScript properly.
CSS became more powerful.
And then our testing
surface area exploded.
This happened.
Now we had to care about the
different interactions and user
experience of all these
different devices.
And this is pretty
much where we are now,
except GIFs are cool
again as long as they're
three megabytes in size and
they're of a cat doing a thing.
But until fairly recently,
we'd taken an odd stance
when it comes to
graphical performance.
Our goal was usable.
Not good, usable.
On machines that could
draw 3D worlds fast enough
to respond to gaming
controls in real time,
we were happy for our
2D, fairly static pages
to perform just a little
bit better than unusable.
Well, that's not
good enough anymore.
Facebook did an experiment
where they artificially
decreased the performance
of their mobile app.
They decreased the frame rate.
It was still usable,
just not as smooth.
And when they did this,
they saw a significant drop
in engagement.
If you're not caring about
graphics performance,
then your users are going
to go to someone who does.
And this wasn't
possible until recently,
because the browsers
didn't really
let us deliver fluid
user experiences.
But they've all
made a leap forward,
all of the browsers, IE,
Chrome, Firefox, Safari.
But as developers, we still
have to meet them halfway.
There's a few things
we have to do in order
to deliver this fluid
user experience.
And DevTools are here to help.
We saw Paul Irish talking
about this earlier.
The Timeline shows you
all of the stuff that's
going on in the background
as Chrome builds up a page.
But what are all these steps?
What do they mean?
And what causes them to happen?
How does the browser
get from data to pixels?
Well, in the beginning,
there is nothing.
And then like a burst
tap, the browser
is sprayed with HTML
text from the internet.
And it will convert that
text into a tree of elements
that we know as the Document
Object Model, the DOM.
This step in the
process is-- I'm
sure you know already--
called parsing.
And this will show up in the
timeline there, parse HTML.
You'll see this as the
page initially loads.
But you'll also see it if
you pass an HTML string
to a particular
JavaScript interface.
It's like inner HTML.
You'll see parsing
happening there.
We haven't drawn
anything at this point.
The screen is still blank.
At this point, the
browser needs to know
what these elements
look like and where
they appear on the page.
And this starts with
a style calculation.
This looks at the CSS
cascade, the style attributes,
your font tags-- if
you're from the '90s--
and it works out which
styles apply to each element.
And this event shows
up on the timeline.
We saw Paul talking about this
earlier, recalculate style.
You'll see this whenever
you load a CSS file,
when you change the style object
on an element, when you change
a class name, or when you
move the DOM tree around.
Some of these elements didn't
get their style calculated.
This paragraph
here and this div,
they didn't get their
style calculated.
And this is because when
we looked at this div,
it turned out to
be display:none.
And this is where the
browser will make a shortcut.
Because there's
no point thinking
about the styles
of these elements,
because they have no impact on
the visual output of the page.
So it will shortcut
at that point.
We haven't drawn anything
at this point, of course.
Because although we know which
styles apply to each element,
we don't know how those styles
interact with each other.
We don't know the size and
position of each element.
To do this, we
create another tree
internally in the
browser, a render tree.
And this knows where
everything sits on the page
and how big it is.
This process is called
layout, and that
appears in the timeline as well.
Changing the DOM
causes a layout.
Style changes may
cause a layout.
If you change the border size of
something, you'll get a layout.
But if you change
the background color,
that doesn't impact where
things appear on the page.
So you don't get a layout there.
But even things like
resizing the browser,
that's going to cause
a layout to happen.
You'll notice that
these trees are similar.
But they're not
exactly the same.
For instance, this heading
here has a render object.
But there's also a
child render object
that doesn't appear in the DOM.
And in this case, this
is a CSS pseudo element,
like Before or After, that will
create itself a render object.
We see this video element here.
This video element has an
element in the render tree.
But in the render
tree there's always
this series of render objects
that aren't in the DOM.
I feel like a
weatherman doing this.
It's great.
So this is the video
element shadow DOM.
These are the
elements that make up
the slider, the volume
control, et cetera.
Also, we have this
div here, which
doesn't appear in the
render tree at all.
And as I said before,
it's display:none.
It has no visual
impact on the page.
So it doesn't go
into the render tree.
We still haven't actually
drawn anything yet, of course.
At some point, the
browser will decide
that an area of the screen is
showing the wrong thing, which
could mean it's blank.
Or you've updated part of it.
And what the browser
will do then,
is it will identify
the render objects that
form part of that page.
And it will create
drawing instructions,
create pixels for that data,
and send them off to the GPU.
And they appear on the screen.
And that process is "paint."
And it'll show you how much was
painted and when it happened.
Paint, of course,
by visual changes,
that can be triggered by DOM
changes, style changes, layout
changes.
But even just highlighting text
on the page, or hover effects,
they're going to cause
paints to happen.
And that's a lot of stuff
for the browser to do.
And we know how to measure it.
But how fast should it be?
We want it to be instant.
But how fast is instant?
The consensus is you want to
update the screen within 100
milliseconds of interaction.
This is an article I see cited.
This is the United
States Department
of Defense design
criteria standard, which
I hope is easier to say in
Korean than it is in English.
These figures are from 1999.
So maybe expectations
are a bit higher now.
But 100 milliseconds still
feels right to respond
to a user interaction.
Let's have a look at an example.
So here I've got these
rainbow colors here.
And if I click on them, they
change to a different color,
the opposite color in the hue.
And the code for that's
really, really simple.
All I'm doing is I'm
looping through all
of these, all the
elements that are here,
assigning them a color.
And then on click
it's going to swap
the color to the opposite hue.
It's pretty quick.
But if we look at our mobile,
it's really, really sluggish.
It feels really, really slow.
Mobile phones are
slower than desktop,
but they're not that slow.
This isn't caused by poor
hardware performance.
This is an event issue.
You see, with mobile
phones you can pinch zoom.
But you can also double
tap to zoom into some text.
And this is a
problem, because it
means on every tap
we have to wait.
We have to wait to see if
you're going to double tap.
And that wait is
300 milliseconds.
And that's there.
So if we're saying 100
milliseconds feels instant,
you are already three times
over that before you even
get a chance to run any
code, which is a big problem.
We could fix this by instead
of using click, or as well
as using click, we
could use touchend.
And that's great.
Oh, it loads faster, excellent.
But at the end of scroll,
ah, we wouldn't expect that.
Because that's still a touchend.
This is how it works
in most browsers.
on iOS, the old Android
browser, and Firefox.
Chrome won't fire a touchend
if scrolling happens.
But I think we're
going to switch
to doing the same
thing as everyone
else just to be consistent.
Everyone's doing it right
according to the specification.
The specification is
really, really vague.
Microsoft's Pointer Event
spec does the right thing.
It specifies what should happen.
And it says, if
scrolling takes place,
you don't fire a pointer up.
Because the events are being
taken over by the hardware.
Unfortunately, there's not
a lot of support for this.
And even then, we'd
only be able to use
this when we're dealing
with events in JavaScript.
What if the user's just
clicking on a check
box or an input or a link?
We want that to
be faster as well.
This library is really great.
It's by the "Financial
Times," called Fastclick.
And what that does is it uses
a series of touch listeners.
But also analyzes how far the
page is scrolled in between
or how far the user's
finger is moved in between.
And it will try and
fire click events
as soon as it can at the
expense of double tap.
You lose the double-tap
gesture, but your clicks
become a whole lot faster.
Alternatively, if you have
a viewport on your page
and it's fixed, double
tap doesn't mean anything,
because you can't zoom.
So we get rid of the
300-millisecond delay,
which is great.
This only works in Chrome on
Android and Firefox on Android.
But even then,
pinch zooming feels
like a really nice
accessibility feature.
And it's something
people expect of the web.
At the moment, in Chrome,
we're looking at ways
that we can get rid of
that 300-millisecond delay,
even on pages with
some degree of zooming.
We're hoping to land
that later this year.
But in the meantime,
the "Financial Times"
Fastclick script is
absolutely brilliant.
So 100 milliseconds
feels instant.
And anything over
that, not so much.
What about this?
This is some snow,
where it animates
one frame every
100 milliseconds.
Here's a touch action, where
this square updates every 100
milliseconds.
100 milliseconds is not
good enough for animation.
And it's not good enough for
continual touch feedback.
If we see our apps
performing like this,
we must ask, what the frames
per second is going on here?
And in that case, it was 10.
10 frames per
second was going on.
And if that's not
good enough, what is?
You'll have to
excuse me, because I
get to nerd out about
frame rates a bit.
When cinema with
audio was introduced,
a standard emerged
that frames should
be 42 milliseconds apart, which
makes it 24 frames per second.
Film, a series of stills
where the light is
shone through the
film, 24 was picked
because film was
quite expensive.
And they wanted to go
as low as possible.
So 24 isn't good.
It was just decided that that's
one better than unwatchable.
And things stayed like that for
90 years, "The Hobbit" being
the first mainstream
film to change that.
That went up to 48
frames per second.
Meanwhile, this was happening.
People were getting
color TVs in the homes.
And in CRT screens, it's
created by an electron
gun, which sounds really sci-fi.
And it looks really
sci-fi as well.
That's a TV electron gun.
It beams a picture starting from
the top, scans to the bottom
and then restarts.
And it did that 60 times
a second here and the US.
In a lot of the rest of
the world, it was 50 times
a second.
That's the refresh
rate of the screen.
And it's also the
maximum frame rate.
50 and 60 were chosen because
it depended on the power supply
frequency of the country.
And back when the
first TVs were out,
it was much cheaper
to make them if you
could rely on the power
supply as the timer
rather than building
that into the TV.
So that's where the
difference comes from.
So some TV shows would go up to
the 50 or 60 frames per second.
Some TV shows would choose to
miss out every other frame.
And it would make them
look more like film
because it would be at 30
or 25 frames per second.
And this is why "The Hobbit,"
at 48 frames per second,
felt like a cheap soap opera
or a computer game to people.
Because it's what they
associate that frame rate with.
Computer monitors could be
driven at different refresh
rates.
50, 60, quite
painful on the eyes.
We tended to drive them
at 75, 100, even 120.
We don't use CRTs anymore.
We use flat screens.
Not as good for cats
to sit on top of,
but better for our eyes.
These screens don't scan in
the same way as CRT screens.
A higher refresh rate
isn't really beneficial.
60 is the most common
one we see now.
You'll encounter the
odd projector or screen
that wants to be at 75.
And some laptops
will go down to 50
when they're running
on battery power.
So when we want smooth
motion, that's our goal.
We want to deliver a new
frame for every refresh
of the screen.
And at 60 hertz, that's
16.67 milliseconds.
That's our deadline.
And that's not long
to edit the DOM,
calculate style, layout, paint.
And on the mobile, you've
got less processing power.
So that feels like less time.
However, most instances
of animation on the web
are shooting
themselves in the foot.
They're not starting
their work early enough.
Or they're overworking
the browser.
Let's see, here's
our refreshers,
each one of them 16.67
milliseconds long.
Say our frame takes 10
milliseconds to construct.
That's great.
That will appear in
the next refresh.
That's when the
user will see it.
But when do we start
building the next frame?
We could go as soon as possible.
This is the code for
that, set timeout, 0.
And that looks like this.
And that work goes
into the refreshes.
However, some of the frames
we created never actually
ended up on the screen.
We were making too many of them.
And this is going to be using
too much of the CPU, which
means too much the battery
on devices with battery.
And at some point,
another application
is going to come along
and go, do you mind?
I would quite like
a go on the CPU now.
And the scheduler will
block what you're doing
and let this other
app have a go.
And you will drop frames.
So this is wrong.
What could we do?
We could do setTimeout, 16.667.
This is pretty much
what jQuery does.
setTimeout and
setInterval only promise
that your function
is going to be called
after the number of
milliseconds you give it.
And it's rounded to an internal
timer that isn't very accurate.
So the first four
frames turn out fine.
But we're out of sync.
The work is starting later
and later into the refresh
until here, when we miss.
We miss our deadline.
That is going to
go into the refresh
after we have skipped a frame.
But this is still 58
frames per second, roughly.
And that's pretty good.
When it comes to
orange juice, who
prefers orange juice with
bits of orange in it,
like, little bits of orange?
One guy, Alex, OK.
Who prefers their
orange juice smooth?
We've got lots of people with no
opinion on orange juice at all.
That's fine.
I prefer it smooth.
I had this debate
with someone at work.
And they said,
no, I like to have
an orange juice that I can chew.
They're going to
be over the moon
when they discover oranges.
It's everything they want.
But imagine you're
drinking a glass of milk.
And when you're drinking
a glass of milk,
a lumpy bit goes
into your mouth.
It's not expected.
It's not nice.
Well, that's like animation.
Animation is like smooth
orange juice, milk and farts.
Lumps are unexpected
and unpleasant.
We don't want them.
Have a look at this.
This snow is animating
at half the refresh rate
of the screen, which is
30 frames per second.
And you study the motion of
some of the bigger bits of snow
as they come down the screen.
It's pretty consistent.
If we go to use setInterval
this is how jQuery does it.
If you follow the
bits of snow down
it's kind of juttery and
jerky as we're getting out
of sync with the refresh rate.
This is a higher frame
rate than we saw before.
But it looks worse
because it's uneven.
It's uneven because
58 frames per second
does not divide into 60 hertz.
It doesn't divide into the
refresh rate of the screen.
The highest possible
frame rate is
less important than
staying divisible
by the screen's refresh rate.
So how do we solve this?
It was mentioned earlier.
We want to use
requestAnimationFrame.
But this is how it works.
It will make sure your
JavaScript is called right
at the start of the
refresh of the screen.
And this gives you the
full 16.67 milliseconds
to get your frame ready.
It gives you the
best possible chance
of making the next refresh.
And that's how this looks,
yeah, completely smooth,
hitting 60 frames per
second and freeing
up the CPU to other
processes in between.
The support for
requestAnimationFrame
is pretty good.
It's been on desktop
browsers for a while.
It's kind of new to Internet
Explorer and Safari.
The story on mobile is
pretty much the same.
It's more recent on some
browsers than others.
But you can polyfill
it really easily.
And it is just dealing
with vendor prefixes
and then falling back to
set timeouts at the end.
All you need to do
here is use Date.now
as your timer and
everything's OK.
As I said, jQuery does
things the wrong way.
It does things the lumpy way.
But a small
extension fixes that.
And if you're doing
animation with jQuery
and you're not using this,
you're kind of doing it wrong.
Because this tiny little bit of
code will make your animation
a whole lot smoother by
using requestAnimationFrame.
The reason jQuery just
doesn't do this by default
is because people have
written code like this.
So here we've got a carousel.
And the carousel is
moving every five seconds
onto the next item.
And then inside, we're
starting an animation.
setInterval will
run all the time,
no matter what's
happening in the browser,
no matter if you're in another
tab or another desktop,
that setInterval
is going to run.
Whereas requestAnimationFrame
is smarter.
It won't run if the user's in
another tab or somewhere else.
It'll save the CPU.
Because the user's not
going to see the result.
However, when you
mix the two, we're
calling the next carousel
item every five seconds
while the user's in another tab.
These animations
are being requested
but never actually happen.
And then the user comes
back into the tab.
20 animations try and start
at once, and the page breaks.
So don't write code like this.
If you're wanting animations to
happen every so many seconds,
don't schedule the next
one until the previous one
has finished.
Because that means the
user can be in another tab.
And it'll just wait.
It'll just wait until
the user returns in order
to continue the animation
or start on the next one.
The idea of syncing
frames to refresh rates
isn't particularly new.
We were talking about
films and TV before.
And there was the
same problem there.
So in Korea we were
running at 60 hertz on TVs.
Modern laptops are also
running at 60 hertz.
But we want to watch modern
TV shows and films on there.
And they run at 24
frames per second.
24 doesn't divide into 60.
So how did we
display films on TVs?
The solution was to do this.
This is called 3:2 pulldown.
This means that the
odd numbered frames
are on screen for
three refreshes.
And the even ones are on
screen for two refreshes.
The odd-numbered
frames are on screen
50% longer than the even ones.
And this is noticeable.
This is really noticeable.
Next time you watch a TV show
or a film on your laptop,
watch out for the smooth
pans across the countryside.
The motion is really,
really juttery.
You can see this effect of
the frames being on the screen
for a different length.
And once you notice it,
you can not unnotice it.
I might have spoiled watching
films on your laptop for you.
But hey, it gets worse.
Your TV, if it's a
reasonably modern TV,
probably supports 24 hertz.
It will go natively
into that refresh rate.
But the application
that's feeding it video
might not tell it to
go into that mode.
And you get the
same problem again.
I know Netflix on
the PS3 is something.
It drives me mad, because
yeah, all the shows
are displaying at the
wrong refresh rate.
We had a different
problem in the UK
because we're on
a 50-hertz screen.
And once again, we want to show
film at 24 frames per second.
24 doesn't divide into
50, but it nearly does.
"Ghostbusters II," in the
UK, is five minutes shorter
than it is here.
Not because you
have extra scenes.
We just play the film quicker.
We go from 24 frames
per second to 25.
And that divides into 50 nicely.
Everyone speaks a little
bit higher pitched,
but you don't really
notice it so much.
So what we've
talked about so far
is all software rendering stuff.
And I want to show the
difference between software
rendering and
hardware rendering.
So we're going to
compare Internet Explorer
6 to what we see
in Chrome today.
So I've got a virtual
machine booting up.
That looks like it's working.
So browsers discovered how
they could do things in the GPU
recently.
And what that resulted--
sorry, hang on.
It did this to me before.
OK, so we might skip this demo.
Hang on.
I'm kidding, of course.
I'm just joking.
But this is a
really good example
of the difference between
hardware and software
rendering.
In Windows XP, the screen
is a single canvas.
The Window Manager knows about
every pixel on the screen,
but nothing more.
The graphical representation
is completely flat.
So if you wanted to move
a window, say this one,
you would click and drag across.
Windows will redraw it
by taking these pixels
and copying them to
the new location.
And then it identifies
areas of the screen that
are now displaying
the wrong thing.
So it would pick up
these free rectangles.
And what it will do is it
will send a message down
to the application now
responsible for those
and tells it to
redraw this area.
So in the case of
this rectangle here,
it says, hey, Control Panel,
you need to redraw that bit.
And it does.
However, with the case of
these other two rectangles,
the message goes to
Internet Explorer.
But Internet
Explorer has crashed.
So it can't deal
with the message.
So those pixels
stay on the screen.
And that's why you
can paint the window
across a screen like that.
That's how that effect happens.
This is software
rendering, a single canvas
of pixels where the CPU
adjusts it pixel by pixel.
Things changed in modern
operating systems like Vista
but also OSX and many
Linux desktop managers.
The desktop isn't a single
flat canvas, but rather
a whole series of canvases all
stored together in the GPU.
In this system, moving a
window is really, really easy,
because the graphics
card knows what
every window looks
like in its entirety.
To move a window, the CPU
just says to the GPU, hey,
you know that thing
you already know about?
Put it over here.
It's a very small instruction.
And the GPU takes the
care of the rest of it.
And once it knows
all the positions,
it composites them
together into the picture
you see on the screen.
If you work in Photoshop,
software rendering
is like a flattened PSD.
If you want to
move something you
have to redraw what
was underneath it,
whereas hardware rendering
is like a layered PSD.
Moving stuff around is
really, really easy.
The web used to
be a flat canvas,
but more and more is
moving to the GPU.
And it's about time.
Because it turns
out, the graphics
processing unit, pretty
good at processing graphics.
We just haven't
really been using it.
Once the web browser
knows where everything's
going to go on the
page, it then decides
that particular elements
deserve to be drawn separately
from the rest.
And once it does that, it'll
draw them all separately
and then join them together
in an operation called
compositing.
And that will appear
in the Timeline.
So here we have two paints
and then a composite
to bring them all together.
You can tell which
elements have GPU layers.
Once again, Paul Irish
showed this this morning.
You would go into the
cog there and turn
on Show composited
layer borders.
And you get this orange
border on everything
that's being accelerated.
And this is updated
in real time, as well.
You can see, also,
this grid over the top.
That's the tiles that
are sent to the GPU.
So each one of
those is a GPU tile.
So we can see here, this is just
part of the background layer.
But when we click it
to spin it around,
we can see it gets a border as
that transformation happens.
So that shows things
on the GPU changing.
So what effect do
these layers have?
So here's a demo
where I've got lots
of these blobs moving
around in a circle.
And the first thing
we need to ask here
is, what the frames
per second is going on?
Because it's not looking great.
Here's what the timeline says.
Every frame's taking
over 100 milliseconds.
It's pretty terrible.
This is happening
the Windows XP way.
We're seeing these
full, large paints
covering the whole canvas.
Every time it changes,
the whole thing
is being cleared and redrawn.
The animation itself
is being driven by CSS.
There's no JavaScript involved.
We're animating top and left.
Each blob animates
with a delay to create
that kind of snake effect.
But what if we added
translateZ, the magic hack?
What if we added that to
every segment of the snake,
with the appropriate
prefix, of course?
We go from this to this.
It's a vast improvement
with that one line.
The timeline agrees as well.
Those massive paints are being
replaced with composites.
And most of our effort's
going into recalculate style
and layout now.
This is working more
like Vista and OSX.
All the CPU is
saying is, hey, you
know those blobs that I
told you about earlier?
Move them over here.
And it all happens on the GPU.
These slides are all
just built in HTML.
And they run smoothly
because it's all just
a series of fades and
transitions, all the stuff
that the GPU can do natively.
So yeah, things like
Rotate, Scale, Skew, Fade,
that's all possible
just purely on the GPU.
So translateZ, we've seen
this a couple of times today.
It makes moving
stuff around faster.
Well, that's a little bean
from the can of Jake's Tipz.
But look closer.
The Best-Before date is today.
And my partner and I
have a little argument
when this happens.
Because as far as
I can tell, she
seems to think
that food is fine.
It is perfect.
And then when midnight strikes
on this date, it is now poison.
And if you so much as touch
it, your face will fall off
and wasps will fly out
of your neck or whatever.
But no, it's just
best before then.
It's probably still OK.
This is what performance
tips are like.
If you just blindly
use them in a project,
things might go wrong.
So when people say something
is faster than something else,
give it a smell first.
Because it might have gone off,
as many rules have already.
Don't trust performance rules.
Use the dev tools to
see what's going on.
On the Chrome team we say
tools, not rules, which rhymes.
So it must be true.
But they're a great
way to discover ways
that you might be
overworking the browser
or ways the browser might
be overworking itself
that you can hack around.
If you find
something, the browser
being slow when you don't think
it should be, report bugs.
I know it's annoying.
And reporting a
bug probably isn't
going to help your
current project,
because you need
to ship tomorrow.
But it might save
your next project.
So translate says it got
us to 30 frames per second,
which is not great.
But it's OK.
But not only is it less
than 60 frames per second,
I've got this button
in the middle.
And when I click
this button, it's
going to run some JavaScript.
And while that JavaScript is
running, the animation stops.
This is because the layout
and style recalculations that
are going on here, they
happen on the same thread
as JavaScript.
So when JavaScript happens,
the animation can't run.
We're currently
animating top and left.
If we switch this
out for a transform,
we get the same effect.
We go from this to this.
And I don't know if you
can tell from there,
but the difference
is astounding.
We've gone from 30 frames
per second down to 60.
But not only are we
down to 60, we're
barely touching
the system at all.
It's taken 1.2 milliseconds
to move 300 objects around.
That's great.
So the calculate
style and layout,
they were on the same thread as
JavaScript, as we saw before.
But composites don't happen on
the same thread as JavaScript.
So if we go back
to the example--
I'm going to click
this button again--
the JavaScript
there is still slow.
It's still going to
take a while to run.
But it doesn't
disrupt the animation.
The animation's happening
on a different thread.
That particular tip, that
could change in the future,
like all of these tips can.
We might start moving
more drawing stuff
off the main thread,
free more stuff up.
But this stuff applies
to mobile, as well.
So we can see, from just
animating top and left--
and now we're a CSS
animation-- the difference is
absolutely huge.
Actually, animating
these transforms
gives us another advantage.
So on the left, I'm
animating top and left.
On the right, I'm
animating using Transform.
And we can see,
with a transform,
it can glide between the
pixels, whereas top and left
snaps from pixel to pixel.
Much smoother if you
can use transforms.
Unfortunately, this
isn't true in Firefox.
In Firefox, if you
use Translate 3D,
it's still going to snap
from pixel to pixel.
And they do this
deliberately for reasons
they haven't explained to me.
But there is a
ticket open for it.
But you can hack around it.
If you add a very, very
small rotate, it fixes it.
It means it can glide
between the pixels.
And it works beautifully.
So if you're wanting smooth
animations in Firefox,
do that for whatever reason
and bug them about it.
Because it's stupid
that we have to do that.
So these layer things
are great, right?
They seem like
this magic bullet.
Let's take away some of
these expensive styles.
Let's get rid of the shadow.
Let's get rid of
the rounded corners.
And let's make the
colors alternate.
So we're going to this.
That's working fine.
But if we take a
look on mobile, we
can see when these
colors change there's
a huge pause in the animation.
There's a huge bit of jank.
And if we remove translateZ,
if we take that out of the mix,
it turns to this.
It's still not a
great frame rate,
but it's much more
consistent than it
is on the left,
where it's stopping
every time the colors change.
What's going on here?
Remote debugging can show us.
And we can see, this is
where the pause is happening,
this huge spike.
And this is where the
colors are changing.
And we can see,
each of those blobs,
each of those squares in this
example has to be repainted.
And that's a lot of effort.
On desktop it's not
too bad, because it's
got a good relationship
with the GPU.
It can get this stuff
done really fast.
But on mobile, redrawing
all of this stuff
separately and
uploading it to the GPU
is actually slower than just
redrawing the whole thing.
If we redraw the
whole thing, as I say,
we've not got a
great frame rate.
But it's consistent.
It'll stay at the same
frame rate throughout.
So we've seen this
translateZ trick
to make layers on the GPU.
But that's not everything.
That's not everything that
can create these layers.
Here are some of the
things that trigger
layers in Safari
and Chrome today.
3D transforms, which
translateZ is one of them.
But also, translate 3D,
rotate 3D, rotate X, rotate Y.
Animating or transitioning
using CSS, a transform property,
an opacity property,
or a filter property
for the duration
of the animation
that will become a GPU layer.
Flash and Silverlight,
to sandbox them,
that will be drawn
completely independently
and then composited
in afterwards.
Canvas, for the canvas'
hardware accelerated,
that will be drawn on
its own, as will video
for the same reasons.
Fixed position elements.
Something we're experimenting
with at the moment
is we're going to make
them their own GPU
layer on retina devices.
But at that moment, as you
saw in Paul's demo earlier,
you can put translateZ on these
things and speed them up a lot.
These can all change
in the future.
This stuff, we're going to be
switching these things out,
whatever's going to give
the best performance on most
of the sites today.
Don't trust the rules.
Use composited borders.
Actually see what's going on
on your page, on your phone
and on your desktop.
WebKit Nightly,
in the dev tools,
they've got a really
cool feature, actually,
where it will list
all of the layers.
And it'll tell you
why they're a layer.
It's not always accurate.
But it's quite a nice feature.
This is something we'll be
getting in Chrome as well.
So these rules will
change with time.
But there's one that won't.
Anything on top of a layer
will become a layer as well.
And that kind of makes
sense, because you
can't layer something
on top of a layer
without it being a layer itself.
But this can have quite a
large impact on the page.
So here I'm going to turn
on composited layer borders.
And this square at the top,
I'm going to give this a 3D
transform.
So just a one pixel
in the y direction.
And as I do that, you
can see, there it goes.
It gets the orange border to
show that it's now a GPU layer.
Now, all the rest of
the text down the page
is position relative.
So that means that it's
higher in the rendering
stack than the boxes.
So the box will
appear underneath it.
And as I move that
box down the page,
we can see this text
goes onto the GPU
and then once the intersect
ends, goes off the GPU.
So this is all using
extra GPU memory
because it's
intersecting with or it's
appearing on top of something,
which is also on the GPU.
And this can end up
consuming more memory
than you maybe intended.
So it's great to
look at the borders
and see what's actually
going onto the GPU.
Because this actually
affects rendering, as well.
If we take a closer look,
you can see the text here.
You see the color fringing.
So on one edge, it
looks orangey brown.
And on the other
edge it looks blue.
This is subpixel
antialiasing, and it
makes text look really
sharp on LCD screens.
But as I move this box down,
when the intersect happens we
drop down to grayscale
antialiasing.
Subpixel antialiasing
can't be done
as part of a
composite operation.
So we fall back to just
black and white antialiasing.
You might have seen this
happen accidentally,
like when an animation triggers,
you see the text rendering
change.
This is why that's happening.
If you've got a
GPU layer and you
want to retain the
superior text rendering
of subpixel antialiasing, if
you give it a solid background
color, you get the effect
back even if it's on the GPU.
So by solid background,
I mean no opacity.
It could be an image.
It could be a gradient.
As long as there's no
transparent pixels.
And remember, things
like border radius,
they introduce transplant
pixels, as well.
So if I add a border on
here, the other side,
we've dropped back down
to grayscale antialiasing.
Unfortunately, Chrome
is more cautious
when it comes to CSS animation.
When an element is
animating with CSS,
it will take everything
that could potentially
appear on top of it
right now, and it
will promote it to a GPU layer.
And this can have
quite a bad effect
on the amount of GPU
memory you're using.
Even if it doesn't intersect,
we see these things, down here,
are going onto the GPU, as well.
Because of this, if you've
got an animating element
it's best to move it to the
top of the rendering stack.
And you can do it simply
with something like z-index.
As soon as I do
z-index 1, OK, it's
appeared on top of the text.
But all the rest of
the page has stopped
getting a GPU layer
per paragraph.
And that can really improve
the speed of things.
Because we've seen the
benefits of layers so far.
And we've seen some places
where they can be slower.
But just having too
many of these layers
can cause a real problem,
not so much on desktop,
but definitely on mobile.
This is the Guardian website.
And it runs at 60
frames per second.
I was filming this with a
30-frames-per-second camera.
So it doesn't look
quite as fast as it is.
But we can see,
from dev tools, it's
running at 60 frames per second.
And the GPU memory it's using
is very little, 20 megabytes.
So that's great.
We want scrolling at
60 frames per second.
But if in remote
debug tools, I'm
going to turn every
element into its own layer.
So just everything that's on
the page, as soon as I hit zero,
every element
becomes a GPU layer.
So I'm scrolling, and
everything's fine.
Everything's fine.
I hit zero.
And the scrolling
just absolutely dies.
And it's actually worse when
you see this in real life
than this recording.
And we can see this here.
We've gone down to like 25
frames per second from 60.
And we can see why it's hitting
the top of the GPU limit.
And then things are
having to swap in and out.
And that's where we're
dropping all of these frames.
Forcing something
onto its own GPU layer
is like drinking a cheap beer.
There are some things that I'm
better at after I drink beer,
like talking to
people and stuff.
I find that quite
difficult normally.
A couple of beers, things
are getting better.
But when I have a few more
beers, talking to people
becomes a lot more
difficult again.
In fact, it becomes
more difficult
than it was before I
had any beer at all.
And that's what
layering is like.
Your desktop
machines, especially
the high-end MacBooks
that I see so many of us
have, they can really
hold the drink.
They can drink all through the
night, and it's not a big deal.
Your phone, I'm sorry,
it's a lightweight.
A couple of these, and it
slurs all over the place.
It can't do scrolling.
It becomes awful.
There are no magic rules around
this layering stuff, none
that will stand
the test of time.
They can make transforming
and fading quicker.
But just don't trust
performance rules.
Test what's going on.
Test what's going
on in the browser.
But always test what's going
on on the phone, as well,
with the different hardware.
So to summarize all
of that, you need
to care about
rendering performance
if you're not already.
Because if you don't,
someone's going
to come out with a product
that does a similar thing.
But they're going to care
about rendering performance.
And that's where
the users will go.
Care about performance
by getting rid
of this 300-millisecond delay.
As a browser, we're
working on it.
And we're going
to fix that soon.
But existing browsers, like iOS
and older versions of Chrome,
use the "Financial
Times" Fastclick,
because it'll just make
it so much snappier.
People have this impression
that the mobile web is slow.
I'm pretty convinced
most of it is
down to this
300-millisecond delay,
because it makes everything
feel so sluggish.
But it's stupidly,
deliberately sluggish
to wait for the double tap.
If you're doing animation,
use requestAnimationFrame.
Give yourself the whole 16
milliseconds to prepare.
And if you're using
CSS animation,
you get the same thing.
It runs through the same timer.
Use GPU layering
to your advantage.
If you've got something
that's doing simple transforms
or moves around a lot,
give it translateZ
or use CSS animations.
And that will become a layer.
But be aware of
times when, if you're
updating the contents
of something frequently,
having that as a GPU layer
could be killing performance,
on your phone, especially.
And avoid too many
GPU layers, as well,
either on purpose
or accidentally
by having your intersectional
animations that
run underneath other elements.
Watch out for that.
And with that, I think
I'm out of time, as well.
So thank you very much.
Cheers.
[APPLAUSE]